à
quelle petite merveille quelle joie de
vivre dans cette île le soleil brûle
hardiment la terre et une petite brise
nous rafraîchit et la nuit à la nuit une
pluie délicate fait pousser les fruits
et les fleurs sans rien abîmer à
casimir casimir
casimir
tiens il n'est pas là
pourtant des profits de ce temps
merveilleux
léonard charmant regard sors de ton
entre calé l'olibrius qui est un
championnat c'est moi mais je retire
l'adjectif charmant et comme vous voulez
vous dit peut être surmonté d'un chapeau
ridicule je voulais que tu profites des
temps merveilleux qu'il fait dehors
la nature est en fait le soleil brille
un brin bref ce n'est pas comme moi vous
ne briller guerre mon vieux je constate
avec tristesse que de plus en plus
mauvais caractère dit qu'il insulte non
non mais dis donc express du mal ont cru
bon je ne veux pas poursuivre plus avant
ce discussions pénibles
on le tient mon regard d'aigle entre
voix julie et françois qui arrive bien
avant de partir d'un conseil renarde
malheur de reprendre leur caractère un
exemple que moi il voudrait que je sois
toujours aimable et souriant mais mais
je ne veux pas en être aussi ridicule
françois et julie bonjour messieurs 10
élèves bons joueurs et bonsoir ce but le
pev bulgare russe a de plus en plus
mauvais caractère je fis
il a dit ce vulgaire renard c'est une
est
un petit peu je dis non il faut
absolument rendre ce léonard un peu usé
m'as tu veux changer son caractère ça
paraît difficile j'ai inclus voilà ce
qu'on va faire on va être très
désagréable avec lui il à voir que c'est
ridicule que c'est grotesque et va
devenir doux et gentil comme nenê ne
fallait pas bête d halanzy très des sacs
rien
salut léonard renard mité sors de ta mal
tu vas finit par sentir le renfermé mais
franchement les junies qu'est ce qu'est
ce qu'ils vont en rien du tout ne fait
pas ses deux têtes d'ayew je fais une
tête parfaitement eu une tête d'ahuri
abruti mais je lui dis plus rien c'est
ma tête à moi oui j adore son attention
je vois monsieur du snop qui reviendra
sur continuons à être des à droite sinon
notre plan mais
mes très chers amis je suis venu en
courant comme un fou parce que j'oublie
ma canne quand on n'a pas de tête il
faut avoir des gens en bat sans doute
mais vous ne l'auriez pas vu par hasard
du dos monsieur du snob mais nous ne
sommes pas chargés de surveiller vos
affaires nous
mais je n'ai pas dit ça vous pouvez peut
être m'aider à la retrouver non
absolument pas nous avons autre chose à
faire qu'à chercher votre ba dinh une ba
dinh une canne années ben incrusté
d'aluminium l'umih news vient julie qui
t'ont ces lieux où l'on voudrait nous
utiliser un à de basses besognes sortant
qu'est ce qui leur prend je suis dit non
plaît-il centre 15 adultes où la vue
elle a roulé là sont la table à
merci léonard merci vous pouvez
m'appeler les eaux
ah bon très bien léo
scheer en scène voulez-vous voir quelque
chose pour vous remettre à m et volonté
léo
c'est du jus de takaroa merci beaucoup
[Musique]
c'est très doux merci beaucoup les
médias dit moi je peux te poser une
question quick a repris sans crainte âge
je vous écoute travers bienveillant à 1
voilà je trouve bien aimable d'un coup
qu'est-ce que tu arrives je suis très
heureux construire du coup j'ai trouvé
france on les junies tellement
désagréable que j'ai décidé de ne plus
jamais être craché
nous avons réussi quoi on joue là pied
fait exprès ça me tente pas vous
toujours des plaisanteries stupide je ne
vous salue tous les dj
[Musique]